hi i'm david jose and today i'm going to
show you how to make my mama's seafood
stuffing
so my mom's seafood stuffing was
actually a recipe that's been passed on
to her from her mom or my grandmother
and back then being that they were
growing up in paducah kentucky a very
small town in the south during what were
sometimes with a very different you know
racial climate there obviously might not
have been the seafood in it but that's
something that my mother decided to add
and she continued and shared the recipe
with me and now it's something that i
love to make during holidays or whenever
she'll come to visit and something that
i'm hoping to share with you all today
a very important step is not to forget
once your cornbread's finished make sure
you take a little toothpick insert it in
and pull it out making sure that it
comes out clean
and with this recipe after you've made
the cornbread you'll basically take it
break it up into a little bowl and kind
of just use your hands to really break
it down so it's going to be a lot easier
for the chicken broth and everything
else to incorporate into it as well as
the spices before we bake it so today
we're going to be adding in some
scallops some shrimp and some crab but
you can choose any seafood that might be
something you'd like i mean one year i
can remember my mom tried to add some
oysters but i don't really like those so
i had to veto that pretty quickly
you want to make sure not to chop your
seafood too big or too small that's why
we quartered our scallops and cut our
shrimp into thirds you want to do your
best to try to make sure that you can
get some seafood in every bite
now when i think of this seafood
stuffing it reminds me often times of
thanksgiving or even christmas just
cooking with my mom and it's something
that always kind of brings a warm
feeling to my heart when i just think
about those moments with family and
thinking about how my grandmother
probably hoped that it would you know
continue on to today and it'll be
something that one day i hope to share
with my children
when i found out that i'd have the
opportunity to make my mom's famous
recipe the excitement quickly turned to
nervousness as she reminded me to make
sure that there was some cranberry sauce
on the plate and that we had just enough
seafood in every bite and to make sure
that we used the same cornbread she does
now you can go and find little things
that will become a part of your recipe
as well and making this i just hope when
she watches that she's proud now when
you take it out you'll definitely smell
that cornbread all of the seasonings
that you included as well as that
wonderful seafood that we chose to
include and that first bite is going to
be warm
smooth rich
and so flavorful that you'll certainly
never forget after your first time
how's it going my name is onya uday
today we're making beef stew the naija
way i cannot remember the first time i
had nigerian beef stew because it's been
a part of my life forever
like most people growing up you know
they got to get mcdonald's and stuff
like that that was not the case in
nigerian household at all i'm one of
five and sometimes my mom was like you
know she didn't feel like giving us
individual plates so the great thing
that she used to do which i found so
funny is she used to put it in like this
really really big bowl think family
style
and give us all a spoon and walk away
and then at that point it was like
free-for-all my mom made makes it
different you know what she had like you
know chucky and all these other uh
beef parts and it's delicious but you
know there's a basic way to make it you
can just have the basic beef part and
that's enough there's different ways you
can do it but
at the end of the day it's all delicious
and you know everyone can agree on good
food it's almost like the
the aroma is like crawling out of the
pot and it's such a lovely smell you can
bring someone you know from down the
street with the smell it's uh it's a
great great aroma you want to eat it
before it's even done
my favorite part of the dish
absolutely has to be when you're just
trying to get every piece
on the spoon like you're trying to get
the rice with the stew and the beef and
then if you're lucky you can get a
little plantain on there as well oh just
it's a mouthful of just happiness
yeah
how often do you get that opportunity to
have such a diverse culinary experience
in 20 minutes like in 20 minutes this is
your one-way ticket to africa come join
us nigerians and eating this delicious
beef stew we invite you and uh we hope
you enjoy it
[Music]
it's delicious you know
oh yes
you